[Musique]
guerra un plat bienne chez nous qu est
ce que vous nous proposez rien donné et
bien aujourd'hui on va parler de la
pomme de terre si vous le voulez bien
c'est bien de chez nous c'est bien
français alors la pomme de terre on va
en faire un gratin qui va accompagner
dans le menu d'aujourd'hui une épaule
d'agneau à la sauge à son ouïe très bon
très bon aromates et puis pour commencer
on va faire une salade de du jardin de
curé
c'est une chose très très drôle mais on
en reparlera peut-être à une autre
émission
après nous allons manger un fromage de
saint-hubert c'est un fromage crémeux
très tendre très agréable et puis pour
finir des figues fraîches et des
framboises à la crème et au 20 mai qu'il
va aussi alors là alors eh bien nous
allons nous avons choisi un peu ya qu un
bordeaux un peu yade de 1973 est un vin
qui est un plein épanouissement qui est
un merveilleux et en plus je le dis pas
cher il faut en profiter rapidement vite
et il resserre à température ambiante
n'ont pas d'opérateurs ambiante il faut
qu'il le soit 14 15 degrés pas plus oui
mais voilà fraîcheur de la cave et on en
mettra également dans les framboises bon
voilà mais auparavant
si vous le voulez bien je vais demander
à monsieur alex à berck est un chef
admirable qui était le chef d'un grand
restaurant parisien qui a longtemps fait
une espèce de gâteau de pommes de terre
puis dans le beurre qui est une petite
merveille
alors on va lui demander de nous montrer
comment on fait ça eh bien il faut avoir
de très belles pommes de terre
c'est-à-dire de la belle de fontenay je
n'utilise que celles ci elles sont
vraiment parfaits et l eau consistante
et elle arrive très bien travaillé nous
la coupe on a près avec tellement
d'aline pas la coupe est très fine très
fines comme pour des pommes de terre
chypre car oui comme des pommes des deux
car chips et puis alors vous les faites
vous les mettez avec du beurre alors là
fut obligé de me retourner pour prendre
le beurre je crois qu'on peut dire qu'il
faut à peu
un kilo de pommes de terre pour 4
personnes à préparer récent g de beurre
et 100 g de beurre
alors voici je vais prendre le manoir
vous avez fait fondre vos 100 g de
préfet j'ai fait clarifier du beurre
clarifié que je vais mettre dans le fond
de ce plat voilà il y en a pas assez
j'en rajouterai un peu et alors je pense
que je commence d'abord à salé le fond
il plaint à tour du moulin poivre et je
commence à prendre mes pommes mais ce
qu'on a oublié de dire aussi c'est que
ces pommes de terre après les avoir
coupé très fine
il faut les laver à grande eau et les
essuyer oui alors maintenant voulais
mélanger bien avec le beurre je vais
commencer à peindre déjà dit au beurre à
nouveau de façon à ce que je
et que je continue
tout est là dans ce premier travail de
la pomme maxime
alors là je viens je la mets au four à
pain ou le four
voilà maintenant
voilà et maintenant il a pu détruire
voilà alors je prends donc ses pommes
opère sur fermement au four et gelé
tasse légèrement
il s'est passé à peu près dix minutes
depuis que vos amis au four au peuple
oui même pas dix minutes faut bien les
égaliser de façon à ce que ne peuvent
pas elles ne vont pas coller et après je
vous ferai voir je vous expliquerai
pourquoi je crie mis beaucoup de beurre
voilà un minutes se sont écoulées à
nouveau maintenant les banques notaires
sont puis voilà il nous reste plus qu'à
aller déguster alex c'est ce que vous
allez faire tout de suite alors le
gratin de pommes de terre c'est un tout
un genre de gratin dauphinois
mais je ne mets pas de fromage d'or et
vous allez voir finalement à la fin ça
va sentir un peu de fromage
comment je pense que c'est le mélange de
dudley de crème et la fécule de pomme de
terre se doit il doit y avoir une
réaction chimique finalement et pourquoi
pas et seul fromage sans fromage ça sent
le fromage mais d'une façon très douce
désagréable allait bien alors c'est très
simple pour quatre personnes
j'ai pris quatre petits plats que j'ai
légèrement beurré je prends 500 g de
pommes de terre un demi litre de lait
oui un quart de crème fraîche du sel du
poivre de lime et vous verrez juin m
très très peu un peu de noix de muscade
et bgc tout bébé puis c'est tout et ça
lui
alors si on a le temps de faire autre
chose dorcel dans la même journée
bon alors que quatre
pour 4 personnes pour 4 personnes alors
les 500 g de pommes de terre on va les
couper en rondelles
comme ça grouillait de ctp sera stoppée
pas trop épaisses ça qu en combien de
temps qu'ils rentrent de près un quart
d'heure vingt minutes
ah bon c'est le sac hui en deux fois
alors la première fois je mets les
pommes de terre dans la casserole
casseroles épaisse mais qu'est-ce qu'on
les pêche où il est préférable parce que
voilà lequel sera bientôt chauffer je
vais ajouter mon demi litre de lait
voilà la casserole avait chauffé mais on
peut le mettre à froid
d'ailleurs il faut le mettre à froid je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi alors j'ai
mis le lait je vais mettre un peu de sel
ça le pouvoir mais dès maintenant un
petit peu de poivre maintenant je mets
tout je mets tous les l'assaisonnement
et les aromates 1 voilà je vais mettre
un petit peu 2004 que je vais rapper
avec mon couteau parce que j'ai oublié
la tegra petit bravo enfin ça c'est pas
nouveau j'oublie tout mais c'est mon
rôle a fâché oubliez le pommes de terre
non pour le gratin bon voilà regardez le
il n'en faut pas trop hein hein parce
que sinon ça sans s'asseoir mme hinse
admin il faut que tous restent subtil et
puis on va prendre un petit peu de die
alors pourquoi personne combien vous
allez olla beaucoup même pas une gousse
les liens tout donnant une petite bêtise
die un soupçon pareil parce qu'il ya un
autre procédé ces deux de frotter le
plat à lier mais je pense que
l'ensemble est plus généreusement les
parfums sont plus généreusement
réparties quand on met tous dans le lait
à cuire avec alors regarder parce que
c'est ça c'est ce que pour 4 oui oui
c'est et puis vous allez voir ça va
sentir ça pas sentir l'aïe en fait il
faut pas que ça sente la y voit là une
pointe de couteau
c'est tout voilà bien alors on va faire
bouillir
alors si vous voulez pas l'instant là eh
bien on va peut-être faire une autre
sorte de de pommes de terre de
préparation alors on va faire un gâteau
de pommes de terre à l'oignon un ça va
être marrant c'est aussi facile
d'ailleurs à réaliser alors je
n'empêcherai chercheurs comme de terre
oui oui alors l'oignon on va le couper
en tranches et puis s'en va passer ça à
la moulinette gel à molinet vous avez la
formidable
alors je vais enlever mes petites
attendait ces boîtes bêtise
voilà alors on va faire un peu comme des
dépôts mbaye si vous voulez c'est un
gâteau de pommes de terre à l'oignon que
l'on sert aussi avec des viandes avec un
oui bien sûr qu'il allait avec également
mais on aurait pu le servir avec
l'épaule d'agneau et ça va ça va de
soucis très très bien
il ya un troisième qui je l'avais pas je
trouvais un peu bancal pour combien de
personnes vous faites le bateau je vous
je vais faire oui je vais faire pour
quatre personnes alors je vais faire ça
regarder danser petit poil c'est des
poils qu'on peut trouver dans le
commerce serait mignon ça c'est joli
parce qu'on peut apporter sa vision
table accord c'est ça s'appelle des
poêle à blinis sellini c'est une espèce
de crêpes crête à base de levure et que
qui accompagnent
alors vous allez mettre les petites
pommes paille oui là dedans oui mais
alors je vais pas pratiquer de la même
façon parce que il faut que j'enlève la
fécule de ses pommes de terre car à la
cuisson c'est c'est cette paille de
pommes de terre se regrouperaient et ça
ferait une une masse et agréable à
manger ses moules voilà alors
alors oui bonjour on va les passer dans
l'eau tout simplement c'est tout et
c'est ça qui empêche les pommes de terre
bien sûr d'adhérer à bien sûr une fois
qu'elles sont rap et on les plonge dans
l'eau oui et on est tranquille mais
c'est un plat qu'on peut manger tout ça
le soir on veut bien les faits rien du
tout à faire si vous avez patients oui
c'est le petit dîner familial exactement
bien alors je vais mettre ça doit il
fini oui moi je veux laver les laver
dans dans l'autre le voilà juste pour
les débats juste pour leur enlever la
fécule en effet l'on devient vite on va
les laisser tremper quelques instants et
pendant ce temps là qu'est ce que je
vais je vais couper l'oignon qui va
servir à les farcir voilà on discute pas
couper le vous même et sangloter dans 4
0 bon alors d'un truc pour pas pleurer
oui des lunettes de moto ce que les
bourriches alem et autres trucs là guy
lofalk lui normal a assuré paraît très
bien alors il ya un truc pour les
oignons
non mais je vous parlais des lunettes de
moto mais ça je les ai vus
un grand restaurant il y avait des dames
qui faisait que ça qui épluche et des
oignons bien sûr on avait donné ça vous
faire mais c'était ce que je vous dis
bon fallait sinon l'histoire de tremper
dans l'autre otage suisse d'aidé des
lunettes de moto oui elle ne pleurait
pas bien et bien alors oui ça c'est bien
voilà c'est encore un peu fermes c'est
parfait alors on va ajouter maintenant
la crème fraîche c'est à dire le quart
de litre de crème fraîche qui va pour 4
personnes 1 oui alors on se souvient un
demi litre de lait et un quart de litre
de crème fraîche et deux hommes de dieu
en personne
oui 500 grammes un ca t1 voilà bonjour
des remue tout ça pour faire dissoudre
la crème
on va laisser donner un bouillon le
temps que ce soit que ça se mélange
voilà et puis on va à garnir les petits
plats pendant ce temps on va prendre la
poêle
donc pour les gâteaux de pommes de terre
à l'oignon on va mettre dedans un peu de
beurre et un peu d'huile pour faire
blondir les oignons et les cuire huile
d'arachide d'olive qu'est ce que vous
préférez michel moi personnellement
j'aime bien l'huile d'olive
enfin parce que c'est une huile très
fruité très agréable en cuisine est
peut-être trop a fumé là pour le dr un
peu trop parfumé parce qu'il ya déjà le
parfum des oignons
alors ce bon passé depuis là que nous
avons il rate le mariage voilà en fait
pas mal parce que l'oignon c'est ça boit
beaucoup la matière grasse bien
très bien bien alors nous allons faire
les deux en même temps je raffole et
nous allons mettre les oignons grimpe le
beurre va être élu ils vont être chauds
et puis on va garnir les petits plats
oui voilà c'est prêt alors nous allons
rentrer s'est plaint garnie de pommes de
terre de gratens au four et les cuire
donc une chaleur me voyais à bord
viennent un bon mondial et la halle au
beurre blanc pour les ogres et le bear
blu 1
c'est à dire blanc voyez on l'entend
chanter là longtemps déchanter très bien
alors il sera blanc quand il chantera
plus ils sont même bien celui là on peut
le garder pour une autre c'est bien
parce qu'il continue de chanter parce
qu'il y ait encore de l'eau dedans et il
commença à colorer quand il n'y a plus
d'eau voile alors nous c'est juste au
moment où il s'arrête de chanter voilà
que l'on jette les oignons vient alors
maintenant nous prenons cette casserole
et nous allons garnir nos plats de
gratens c'est délicatement
là on va répartir les pommes de terre
dans les quatre plats les oignons
voulait surveiller pages les surveille
ça va 100 ça devrait aller
je vous rajouterez de la crème après non
non c'est tout on va rajouter le liquide
le mélange de beurre et de pardon de
l'est de crème sur les pommes de terre
et puis c'est tout donc maintenant il ya
plus à ces zones et tout est dans le
plat tout et tout est fait et il faut en
somme les c'est gratiné et les scellés
cédric voilà deux rails tout simplement
voilà alors on égalise un peu partout
comme ça voilà c'est tout alors je vais
prendre une cuillère
donc oui une petite louche ce jour n'est
pas mais c'est pas grave paura c'est ça
vous mettez en blesser avant mais tout
l'art cet été est étudié pour que ça
tombe juste il est un peu cheap larrouy
pourriez-vous il reste plus rien dans la
casserole
voilà tout est terminé voilà un coup
très bien allez hop là voilà et
maintenant nous allons rentrer au four
et pendant ce temps nous allons avoir
nous allons finir le legato de pommes de
terre à l'oignon voilà bien et vous
comptez une dizaine de minutes
maintenant
on regardera conditions peut compter un
procès doré on peut compter un petit
coeur de mon ouïe ouïe courriel six ou
sept minutes à peu près si oui non
l'époque assaisonner les oignons avant
ça elle
un petit peu oui toi fois en fait les
oignons vont servir un four et ses
galettes de pommes de terre avait au
centre de la galette bien alors les
pommes de terre ont lésé groupe
attendait donc elles ont rendu saïano
les troupes rebelles sont elles sont
fermes maintenant voyez oui mais
tiennent très bien nous allons les
éponges et g13 sont aussi voilà voilà
très bien voilà parfait
il y en a un qui serait content si vous
voyez nous activer comme ça c'est
parmentier a pas menti
c'est une chose que c'est pas lui qui a
trouvé la pomme de terre vous savez oui
ça cesse et laisser les soldats de
comment il s'appelait depuis la dette
espagnole ses des soldats de pizarro
pizarro qui ont trouvé ça au pérou mais
c'est parmentier qui a inventé le hachis
non non non le pauvre a menti on a
failli on a failli prendre son nom pour
pour appeler les pommes de terre
finalement ça n'a pas marché mais c'est
ce qu'il avait offert à louise cette
histoire ravissante oui c'est avec louis
saez donc ces chantiers qui a relancé la
pomme de terre en france et à la fruit
d'une famine en 1769
ça a été le public menée chez un
importateur exactement et alors il a
remporté le concours
mais il n'y avait pas tellement de
clients pour manger la pomme de terre
parce que pendant très longtemps on a
cru que la pomme de terre donnée la
lèpre à bout oui alors il n'y avait pas
tellement le client il a fallu la
famille savait pas alors que les gens se
décident à manger de la pomme de terre
alors ils ont risqué la lèpre
tranquillement quand on a faim mais
enfin on peut dire que c'est que c'est
commun
me c'est ce qui a mis un peu la pomme de
terre sur orbite par le truchement de de
parmentier
alors il est bien aussi un champ au
sablon donc à neuilly actuellement et il
a fait pousser ses pommes de terre ça a
bien marché en pleine campagne en plein
deuil d'une campagne
exactement
et ma foi bombay tout s'est très bien
passé il ya eu d'ailleurs une très jolie
cérémonie à versailles pour la première
récolte
oui c'était mais c'était peu c'était en
1785 je crois parmentier a offert des
fleurs de pommes de terre au roi qui
s'est mis les fleurs de vol de terres à
la boutonnière et louis saez lui aurait
dit écoutez monsieur ce que vous faites
pour nous n'a pas de prix embrasser donc
la reine alors hilarité tout rouge comme
une pomme de terre de hollande il est
veuf il est venu embrasser la paix en
bresse elle a donné une fleur la mise on
se passionne la mise en scène joue dans
son corps dans ses choix on n'aurait pas
retrouvé
enfin c'est joli je pense que c'est une
mode à relancer et puis c'est une jeune
histoire tous les hommes de terre
permettez madame que je déprime quelques
fleurs de pommes de terre à vos pieds ce
que c'est joli
bon alors maintenant nous non pas il
maintenant faut travailler un peu oui
alors j'ai mis un petit peu d'huile et
puis je vais mettre un petit peu peur
maintenant dans les petit poil comme ça
voilà c'est formidable ça me va très
bien chaufferie et puis je verrai partir
voilà comme ça
les pommes de terre ou et j'en ai
beaucoup trop finalement j'ai fait j'ai
eu la main lourde dans les petites fois
le bien non ça valait finalement non non
c'est red savarin les assaisonner et
bien il faut qu'elle colore et qu'elles
cuisent par contre quand même temps
comme une pomme de terre frites au sac
huile a noté ça va bien oui très bien
aussi merveilleux c'est pas dedans au
fond du foulard en soie dans la santé
mais ils ont l'air heureux bien résumé
de tous mes copains on est jaloux
voilà alors on va mettre maintenant le
la marmelade d'oignons au milieu donc
donc vous avez laissé les oignons sur
une plaque tiède à ces rencontres de la
cuillère non ils n'ont pas continué dans
et hors les sages auraient pu les mettre
froid d'ailleurs j'aurais pu faire ça
ils ont de l'importance en fait la
température
la chaleur qui sert à cuire les pommes
pas il a suffi pour réchauffer tous
ensemble un bon alors voilà c'est coloré
là en dessous on va remettre les pommes
de terre dessus
ah bon oui c'est déjà de reims où vous
remettez les pommes pas pris parce que
il faut que le l'oignon soit enfermé à
l'intérieur de ce gâteau un et vous
attendez que ce soit déjà doré pourquoi
vous le faites pas au début ça j'ai pas
compris comment ça il faut que ce soit
dorée des deux côtés donc je vais
retourner avoue juste avant de retourner
vous mettez la pomme de terre
oui c'est ça mais j'aurais pu le mettre
avant que j'ai tellement de choses à
faire et c'est ça
ah bon michel ans maintenant ça y est
j'ai compris bien voilà ah oui c'est
tout d'or rios que ça va être bon c'est
mieux oui voilà bon opus adore aussi si
c'est vrai ça dort partout ça veut dire
que le coût de marche et les plaque tout
et dorures une fois qu'on l'a retourné à
peu près 5 6 minutes
voilà c'est ça bon voilà c'est vraiment
rapide un peu de coeur pour un peu de
beurre serait au fond du fond du lait
très bien son dû a refait très très bien
voilà
et voila voila mais ça va être prêt oui
dans 5 minutes bien et alors notre place
et on en fait pas trop les laisser ma
commune mais ça va être très bien ils
sont bons ils sont photogénique
oui ils sont louis qui y sont
photogénique sa formation qui sont bruns
et zone
eh bien on va les sortes allait enfin on
va pouvoir tout donner en même temps
voilà
[Musique]
et là vous ne vous lassez années en vue
non non non si vous ne mettez plus un
peu de poivre un peu tu as l'air l'eau
tout tout est prêt ça doit coûter près à
la fin de tout doit être terminé
voilà enfin vous voyez je ne mentait pas
voilà très bien et maintenant nos petits
gâteaux vont ils sont presque prêts
également à la voyons on aurait pu les
laisser deux minutes de plus un truc et
plus marrant nous pas complètement mais
peut-être un peu plus en bray est un
petit peu plus réduit mais enfin c'est
très bien parce que tels qu'ils sont là
il présente un avantage c'est qu'il
peuvent attendre
l'aménageur à café simple les avis des
sentences tard est important israël elle
sort ses gâteaux comment les elle sort
ses gratte en commun on les a sortis
sous vide à dire qu'il reste encore un
peu de crème de lait liquide et elle les
met sur les laisse de côté et quand les
arts et les invités arrivent au moment
où elle où elle sert la salade salade du
curé elle remet ça à court d'eau
[Musique]